all right so it's kind of embarrassing
to admit but I've never played you know
on my stream and I begged my entire chat
to teach me how to play
no I feel embarrassed to admit I've
never played like a children's card game
it's not a children let's get one thing
out of the way first this is not this is
a highly competitive extremely stressful
game for adults for a dog you don't know
the cutthroat you're not you're gonna
we're not gonna be friends after this
I'm glad that I feel like we're all at
least me and Jax LaShawn equally
clueless terms of endearment
are we ready yep all right once we go in
it's it's blood oh my god your mic just
what happened to your bike my oh my god
it's so loud there's a lot of rules that
are different in this one what are the
rules
alright so sevens can change hands with
whoever you pick zeroes rotate the hands
you stack plus twos you can jump in at
any time you played this I can't
remember that [ __ ] just be ready to jump
in the two most important are the sevens
and this year's seven you swap with who
you want when you do is zero everybody
rotates day
really d dammit which reactions thank
you thank you
I'll take that look I just wanted to see
what he had that's what you get that's
what you get
your head okay I'm gonna challenge this
way I know yeah that's how we're goddamn
it you know I just learned what
challenging is that oh you didn't know
about challenge yeah no I didn't that is
apparently not a rule in normal yeah
that's how it goes for you yellow you
got have to you you think that's half
the deck that is hilarious
has anyone ever gotten up to triple
digits that's what I don't know Red Bull
so the cards are just unlimited I
wouldn't doubt no yeah there's unlimited
number of cards here everything um I got
a lot of cards what are you gonna kick
our ass Todd dammit what I would kick
your ass if you would give me a chance
to do so I would love to kick your ass
oh come on pudding I feel like I need a
picture
I feel like mark staring at me yes yes I
am I would love to play pudding I have
to do it to you puddings crying it is
what it is and now you're gonna be
crying fine my time has come
[Laughter]
I'm crying jokesters around here yeah oh
dude interesting interesting interesting
what holy [ __ ] what skill what are you
talking about what this game all skill
hey I put it paid by mark apply hey just
cuz I made the game does not meet what
the hell is in my quarters never
challenged when they don't have a lot of
cards I think a well those are very
different things
no I'm good man thank you it's fine
whatever putting a long game you're
gonna be there with 16 cards sorry
none of them are playable you can't be
sorry at least don't let the AI win
alright I'll try not to let the AI win
make the conscious choice not to do that
[Music]
behold my 9 Oh but gamers behold my
behold my 9 nice answer on that it's not
a 9 what what are we even playing yeah
why blue it was blue let's get it like I
acted surprised after you put it down
like you didn't know what it was gonna
do cards for ya
or would you like some more don't you
dare oh you just decreased it from 4 to
2 ha ha yes this is what I was talking
about challenge me do it do it at Darien
mm-hmm well I drew it rule of uno if I
draw the plus 4 I did not lie oh my god
that is the rule of really pulling a
dish on air hey blue would be really
cool I'm just saying if you if you did
big big huge huge stack of God dude full
scented on that one we using streamer
terms here no one on YouTube is allowed
to say one let's go and number two full
sin none of those
this is YouTube territory now no no no
that's a mixer term you can't say any of
that okay how come the bot keeps winning
this is a good question it's because we
all are at each other's throats and we
need to work together yes yes yes five
you say I'm jumping five do not not do a
five I have three fives it would have
been so cool I haven't ate them what you
have to say uno [ __ ] that's rule number
two of uno yeah well I was waiting for
you to make weight after me no you five
oh come on not not that color no that
was not okay it was all right look if
Jay Sean was next to me I'd be getting a
hundred I'm een outputting might win
this anywhere okay who's got the faster
fingers you have to if you swim if you
get one card from a trade you have to
hit yeah but the others can jump in and
accuse you they can Jew keels Hughes
Sean and GL
around here come on no that's the
opposite no all right I'm doing this for
the team I would use this on any one of
you though just wanna throw that between
nine and 11 cards mine's gonna change
very quickly
you sure can you sure can it didn't mean
you can jump in just Sean how good your
cards pretty awesome
[Music]
sup with my cards no thanks we're good
I'm good actually thank you I'm good
yeah breach no no what who are you use
bttv emotes no Jack keeps telling me I
should no no I downloaded it once and I
couldn't deal with it so I just I
disabled it and all right here we go
this hand is great someone playing wait
this is awesome love that for me
Oh epic this game is awesome it's about
having fun hey keep drawing Oh see
threes ICC's of thank you it's always
putting it was me i won and then i yeah
and then he let me win i skill not win
you say that you say that wait why did I
jump that no I think I didn't want to
jump in on that
I call anything people in at home so no
I'm winning what do you talk about rough
okay great guys please what even cares
that is a bad mood maybe maybe oh now he
doesn't know should you challenge it no
[ __ ] Oh anytime someone jumps in with a
+4 they did it excuse my cards no you
got Plus do somehow doubt that it's ok
it's so early in the game I'll challenge
it a lot of cards I was a pretty easy
challenge
yeah that's pretty bold move whatever
it's cool I definitely did not want that
to be a yellow not at all all right she
wants it to be yellow change it no I was
I was so ready to hit the challenge but
not ready welcome
I am so good at this game don't you dare
don't don't no see that's not
spoke a little bit to Asuna why is no
one laughing at pudding haha putting
losers now don't feel bad they're
horrible monstrosity that's mean huge
huge
would you like to have more cards than
pudding pudding don't do it okay good
okay
all right my cards all right very good
I don't I have no idea what I'm doing
I'm gonna take your these weren't good
at all that doesn't that's not right
that's a twitch thing here in YouTube
and playing who know dishonest all the
way
Olli mmm-hmm well no I won't i won't
keep drawing friends ears my bet you had
something else to do i just drew it
well alright you know what 50/50 shot on
that one
what did you shot mm-hmm yeah thank you
I mean what's the [ __ ] difference
yeah
Siri stop listening into my
conversations oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I was
gonna I was I feel like you wouldn't
have complimented me when if I had done
that those were my cards so saying I
need I need a hype man sometimes I need
listen you've won
Oh someone has hit 30 before I feel like
it was my buddy comments already yeah
less cards no no no God oh that's so
much blue the poky look at that you do
[Music]
just keep doing this instead yeah well
you know
it's my second time it's all good yeah
well this is the third round so you know
there's never enough practice to get to
my level of skill in thousands of hours
maybe it is like extra big because you
know it has a seven now big brain that's
a youtuber term yeah it started out over
here I mean on Twitch we say five head
if you know what that looks yeah yeah
yeah I got I've got I have one of those
[Music]
turntables
okay I'd like to play red guys the spec
is cursed guys it's cursed it's cursed
it's cars oh it's not cursed if one of
these is a seven though it's fine well
you know what have we learned
okay good we learned our lesson here we
learned it yeah good pop get in there I
wait no I tried to stop I tried to stop
I I might in a while I try I didn't want
this to happen like that James I didn't
want that to go down like that man you
gotta understand it comes around I don't
deserve that
be very clear red good myself
someone's got a lot of blue why are you
guys like actually paying attention with
a lot of blue that's really all I don't
have red I need to say
no I'm not the one with the blue deck I
don't know who has the blue deck putting
now I mean this is kind of nice because
we all have a lot of cards yeah this is
great
not all of us guys guys not let's be
clear not all of us have a lot of cards
not all of us some of us have quite a
few densha to my english you know what
don't wait no stop that's not what I was
no yeah it was it was really nice that
works well I mean we could just keep
doing it okay why does putting up such
good hands
well it was a really nice hand deck
thing oh they call stop I wanna play
you're falling right into his trap now
you're falling right into his trap it's
over Anakin
what the hell is with your guys's cards
what just happened
from yellow no no see I'm doing this oh
oh no but I didn't think you would have
that all right what are the odds he has
another green guys see see see I knew I
knew I knew guys you don't trust sorry
sorry
yeah don't leave a yellow wait you also
have three cards guys remember when I
had the least amount of cars guys were
cool that's fun I loved it you loved it
we all loved it I don't understand how
you guys jumped in so many times it's
like it's illogical you can't just say
that and exploit that dude doesn't
explain nothing I guess I'll go okay you
just I will take that and everyone just
calm down they're all playing that game
yeah yeah the Texas that was we worth
one bull and it my editor put in
name of it right here yeah my favorite
episode the opposite when we were I will
see what happens wow that sucks for you
oh yes I mean all that Oh No
all right okay well my heart is pounding
okay
it is a Mexican standoff here now is
that was it was Texas a new six know
which one you gotta take which one's
gonna be which ones go ahead you'll
never know you'll never know okay none
of us win wait on we all lose oh well
here's my chance yes all right what
color do you have blue yeah I don't
believe in Italy I don't believe I don't
know we don't think oh my god that's
real just Shawn move there oh that's a
shame you trying to be cool no never
mind
maybe two Shawn oh you haven't played
with my buddy Wayne oh no
you know where yes you have actually
you've played with interesting okay
anyone got a second interesting wait
damn it your quick ones it's not mark
waiting another one when I win everybody
wins
I just want to point that out yeah
Mark's been saying that for years
the rising tide raises all ships don't
take my ship no that's not the same no
it's my ship that raises apart from your
ship what's Mark her ship is gonna raise
yours that's a very coveted ship yes
yeah oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we got ourselves a
game okay maybe nurse elves a never
ending game hey look we're back to the
beginning of the game this was at least
ten minutes ago it was the very
beginning of the game you start with
seven cards
oh nice or even it feels kind of nice it
is nice isn't that rising tide for the
record for longest uno game ever yeah
Guinness World Record we're gonna be
here until the lockdown stop
I like it so bad puddin but it's awful
what don't talk about him like he's good
she G they I don't know yeah I don't
know either what you got what you got
Canada it's just are you Canadian yeah
when you hear the French accent you know
I got nothing against Canadians I like
that you have bagged milk I do know that
okay this is have you tried beg no I
drove up to Canada to get back just
incredible isn't it so nice so do you
have one of the containers for it I
don't still have bagged milk I live in
the good old America where we where we
have jug milk but if you're gonna try
bag milk you need to buy it doesn't make
the milk I know about the milk container
but listen you back off Ireland or you
go do that
you back off my hands were completely
off the you really gonna do the good old
Canadian like that listen there's
nothing wrong with Canada and there's
nothing wrong with bag note I just like
as so long as you're drinking whole milk
right full fat milk that's all that
really matters
what's wrong with like less or more than
whole milk because that's good for you
oh no here we go there's a Miss there's
been more than scientific studies the
lack of fat yes because it route gets
replaced with sugar okay here's the
whole thing oh my god in in America in
America they're lower there's an obesity
like epidemic and it's cost directly you
can trace it all back to the the the the
the belief no no no he loved his fat you
know he did not it's not Lincoln look
full fat fat is good for you you need
fat there was this belief that fat like
causes all these diseases it's not true
it's
Trudeau no it's too much no you can have
all the fat you want you can have all
the money yeah I might just do that you
can do keep how did I get 11 cards you
shouldn't you shouldn't you need fat to
live that that's important it's what
gives things flavor so you get
unsaturated fat though is the good one
yeah you don't want the trans fat no no
no no no we're on YouTube
I was twitching for you
no that's what you get when I think
about it it's kind of a two versus one
vote two people want to twitch one
person does it oh you're not letting
pudding
you're not letting pudding say his piece
what did I do all right
I'm winning rising tide rising tide
everyone all ships anyway back to my
speech about fat fats good for you it's
surprisingly good for you because
goddamnit
I had a yellow I had sugar sugar turns
God sure sugar I was gonna win I even
believe you didn't jump in just Shawn I
would have won again hey
I would want that name out of your mouth
just sure I know I bet you I bet you're
a dirty sugar eater I bet that's what
you are supposed to a healthy fat oh who
has four now me I'm good why did I jump
in I'll take yours
why thank you thank you very much
look you keep your ten cards you're good
there
[Music]
do you drink full fat milk there in the
UK yeah good good I think points of it
with my dinner I used to be me to like
gala tweet me and my brother we'd crush
a gallon of milk alike every day we
drink milk like real humans you know I'm
not bringing sex into this it's you it's
like human ten cards and not a single
one that works here yeah keep your
TennCare team here nice car nice car and
s [ __ ] you must drink whole milk Wow
pokey what you doing there was it your
turn I thought it was puddings this is
her turn and she didn't take it oh wow
that's unfortunate oh my
my god oh my god 21 cards I don't have a
single red that's unfortunate so many
cards that it stacks them and you can't
even see them all yeah you saved me
thank you because I was switching the
car thank you thank you
someone had to keep it red I did honest
I thought he was like saying thank you
because he wanted a color aside from
that I was thanking you because you not
only saved me from the +4 but you you
rose the tide to allow me to talk really
got my brain there's no way he also
didn't have nothing - okay remember when
we were making fun of just Shawn that
was a cool time lack of fat yeah you
ever eaten avocado it's life-changing
yeah okay like have you ever had avocado
and then you like put it on bread I
think they couldn't like
don't wanna for doubt your point of this
then you hit the Jimmy John's day it's
just so good there isn't even a 104 and
Jimmy John's is non-native to LA so
you're wrong all right it's the 405 or
the 101 I just love to go down to like
like the Americana and hit Sephora just
get all of my a bit those are correct
statements and i apprec-- but it's my
time for Shawn to win oh how did you get
one wait well I keep not paying
attention we keep doing bits
I don't allow other people to win yellow
I'm gonna keep that in mind okay no no
stop no he doesn't have a yellow no the
takeaway from that was that he did not
yes that's the one the bots I don't
think the bots in our discord I don't
accept friend requests from just anybody
so you know yeah you got drink whole
milk to be a friend on okay we need to
play yellow right yes yeah yellow I
think we're far past that wait no it's
because you have yellow wait no I see I
see I see what's going on
see oh wait [ __ ] oh god no wait stop
stop my turn I was I legitimately I was
too busy being an [ __ ]
I didn't I that was actually no not that
Cup no not blue but like one step ahead
always work nabis cries I'm just Shawn
she's learned too quickly
oh how much time you got pokey I could
do one more round let's do one more
let's mix it up Shawn round is it is it
the juice genre no I'm too much of a
[ __ ] dumbass to know what's going on
outputting I am just happy to be
pathetic pathetic terrible are you guys
good with impressions or accents that's
the one thing I absolutely just Kendall
did somebody say accents you asked my
fans like don't you dare make fun I I
don't even care that this is me make fun
of me
potatoes alpha you know you know you you
always order potatoes yeah I got man
also when I took out puddings Garcia 3/7
Oh Issei talk it sounds like like like
Tok Tok no he's literally medic took no
he said the word took no he actually
said took I think cuz he said when he
when he took the card said I'm pretty
sure that's yeah he actually said it was
meant to sound that way what I'm still
drawing cards wait what I
unintentionally won
I didn't know you could plus two uno and
then plus to yourself yeah I did we
could do another round we need you Sean
to we know we don't know we don't need
yeah okay cute little gesture needs to
have a dubbing is cool
yeah exactly
yeah yeah yeah you're getting destroyed
I can't believe it yeah you know he's
Irish wait no my cards I had no no those
I'll really like those guys
that's actually really good I know right
pretty good those are game-winning cards
those were yes they were winter cards
speaking of being winter cards
interesting interesting move here
interesting interesting interesting ico
days we got a couple of [ __ ] sweat
he's over here no no it's it's kill or
be killed
milk and sugar good move yeah you want
to talk more about that okay I could
talk more about that about not green I
I enjoyed green I will say oh I know
that's why I'm saying how about it we'll
see then I will pass it back that's what
I will I'm gonna pull a risky I'm gonna
kill him anew ver here I had a wild card
okay okay that's good that's good
why do you get it on the first draw and
I have to draw ten
cuz you won three games because I'm good
okay cuz I got skill do you know what
color that card is I don't know well
maybe you'll figure it out by getting
another four how does that make you feel
good a beating of the one who's in the
dirt versus the one who clearly are you
challenging you but I don't have a
reverse card that's
interesting interesting you know what
else is a lot what what my subscriber
count it's pretty high it's very a lot
it's very high so I have that what
you're dropping your sub count guys you
know the subs are a little low this one
maybe hit the subscribe button right
there sue sue oh it's my turn Jesus
Christ god no God stop wait no no God I
didn't I can't wait for my comments at
home to tell me how many times I
could've what didn't ya
cuz just Sean's a bit of a judo mess hey
you want my cards I'm okay wait can I
pull I don't even want my cards excuse
me mr. Jin dumbass I've got cards here
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay you're not sorry I know you're not
don't even say it
[Music]
of course I know I just have to pick up
20 yes who know is like that it doesn't
know no does not yeah what are you doing
get out of here with those cards will
you will ya
how do I unbelievable that's interesting
I like that color on us mm I mean I
don't mind it for now until green snot
is cool but you know take it okay I like
this nice normal you know okay well a
pudding can do a pudding do but this
nice okay I had to save blue into
various two guys ah there we go
we have funnier Wow we're nuts
that's not holding that hand for me
pudding it's not bad
interesting interesting whatevs these
don't they were both so good for me oh
my god
why wait no stop that's no stop [ __ ]
pudding come on man you know what what
thanks to Shawn
our problem hey this is a nice cards no
oh no that's not glory I think it's a
green water
[Music]
oh yes this is looking pretty good guys
[Laughter]
I don't even know what to be excited or
sad about I'd rather pass kidney stones
come on yeah that's a good color I do
like you you like yellow after this and
only night well what a waste it doesn't
stack if you do it yourself but it's
taxed by that thank you Jesus oh wait
well no we're done the joke was over
wait stop maybe we could run it back
yeah maybe huh okay guys guys dude
really not us okay that works ours it's
okay it's your turn just Shawn
yeah sure no we like yellow we like
yellow in all ways I don't putting
winning
okay sorry okay what's happening pick me
up please
I'm scared
you just you just god I was gonna say
police don't let him have the same color
all right you know how did everybody win
even the but except I guess well Gigi's
Gigi's now now that's twitch talk here
are you do we say [ __ ] you ie you and
then YouTube you say please like comment
and subscribe
that's the one hey thanks for doing my I
got it
[Music]